this is not a tech problem it's a
distribution problem I think you said it
really well people don't understand that
they say well I've created this
interesting thing therefore everyone
will buy it yeah they're actually
unfortunately wrong I think that what I
always say is if you have amazing
distribution in a ship product you're
gonna win you won't have amazing
distribution and amazing product you're
gonna dominate yeah if so it's kind of
like Kylie Jenner right she has a huge
tribution channel she owns this is
relationship with millions and millions
people and by the way that's I think
about my startup back in 2011 we fell
into the trap you just said it's not
gonna go we built a really great product
Dave so that's so much time and effort
on product and we had no idea how to
distribute it through this long tail of
like schools and teachers are trying to
sell - right from the heart
Oh impossible because a person who buys
is not the person who pays there's like
a you've either this crazy cash crunch
every month or it's like Oh even though
I have committed ARR of you know a
hundred grand revver it is hundred K I
in fact have real ARR of zero because it
goes through like provisioning and goes
through the accounting cycle like in the
district if you don't get the money for
six months after the exercise the
contract
[Music]
you